Should I brew more?
Still warm, and
it's been awhile.
But the Law of Cooling
is a decaying exponential.
But you need a measurement
on the liquid to get the heat
transfer coefficient.
Don't worry about the
measurement for now.
We'll find a new way
to think about it.
All right, so
forget the T entirely.
What if we thought of
molecules like people.
Yes, moving at
impossible speeds,
bumping into one another!
And the amount
of pressure people
feel can be understood by how
frequently these bumps happen.
More people, more pressure.
No, not necessarily.
How big is the room?
Say they're crammed
into a crowded hallway,
jostling and bumping,
late for class.
High pressure, yes?
[laughing]
Mileva, are you all right?
I am.
Now let's place them in a grand
ballroom, the same people.
No more, no less, only
now 10 times the size.
Enough to dance freely
around the room.
More volume.
Fewer collisions.
BOTH: Lower pressure.
[MUSIC - RICHARD STRAUSS, "BLUE
DANUBE"]
Let's write a paper together.
On what?
This isn't a new thought.
Just a new way of seeing it.
What if this is
the way to prove
the existence of molecules?
Doesn't it sound
like fun, dolly?
You and me writing a paper
that could change the world.
And probability of chaos.
Not the title I would
choose, but we can discuss it.